[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation je suis
aujourd'hui avec Anne-claire Chauvency
présidente de l'association Action
protection animale bonjour bonjour Alors
action protection animale a été fondée
en 2020 elle est donc très récente
qu'est-ce qui a poussé justement à la
création de cette association alors le
principal facteur en fait il y a motivé
la création de l'association Action
protection animale c'est vraiment un
constat d'avoir de plus en plus de
signalements pour des faits de mauvais
traitement et finalement avoir un peu de
mal à assumer l'association avait du mal
à assumer en fait le traitement de ces
signalements là parce que voilà les
associations sont voilà font des refuges
des dispensaires etc il y avait pas
d'associations dédiées expressément à la
maltraitance animale et c'est ce qui
nous a motivé finalement à créer cette
structure là qui ne se consacrerait qu'à
gérer les cas de maltraitance animale et
pour bien définir vous êtes seulement
centré sur l'Île-de-France où vous êtes
justement dans toute la France alors on
est nationale donc on intervient sur
toute la France grâce à un réseau de
bénévoles qu'on a un petit peu partout
en France et qu'on envoie vérifier les
cas de maltraitance qui ne sont signalés
de professionnels de la protection
animale en octobre 2022 le ministère de
l'Intérieur a publié une étude sur les
atteintes envers les animaux et
l'évolution entre 2016 et 2021 la cause
animale semble toucher la grande
majorité des français on l'a vu
notamment pendant la campagne
présidentielle et pourtant le constat
est alarmant puisque les maltraitances
animales ont augmenté en tout cas le
nombre de mis en cause et plus important
concrètement est-ce que la justice
répond suffisamment face à la
maltraitance animale alors on a envie de
répondre que non évidemment qu'on a le
sentiment qu'on répond jamais
suffisamment judiciairement à la
maltraitance animale maintenant le fait
qu'il y ait des statistiques qui
démontrent qu'il est entre guillemets de
plus en plus de maltraitance animale
pour moi ça renvoie surtout au fait
qu'il y a surtout de plus en plus
d'affaires qui sont traitées
judiciairement donc c'est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose au contraire on peut
voir ça d'un point de vue positif on
peut se dire que bah la police la
gendarmerie les autorités judiciaires
prennent de plus en plus conscience de
l'importance de traiter ces affaires là
ce qui amène à des dossiers qui sont
traités de manière plus importante et
donc des infractions qui sont qui sont
en hausse pour bien définir justement ce
qu'est une maltraitance animale quand
commence-t-elle et comment est-ce qu'on
peut la définir alors il va y avoir deux
types de maltraitance il va y avoir la
maltraitance légale donc là ça va être
tout ce qui va être contraire au droit
par exemple de frapper un chien par
exemple de le faire vivre à la tâche
dans ses excréments ne pas le nourrir
etc et il va y avoir la maltraitance
morale donc là ça va être de ne pas
respecter son bien-être par exemple en
faisant vivre un chien H24 dans un
jardin en soi c'est pas illégal par
contre c'est une forme de maltraitance
parce qu'évidemment l'animal a besoin de
sortir donc voilà nous on intervient que
sur la maltraitance légale parce que
c'est les textes qui nous permettent en
fait d'agir et on ne peut pas intervenir
sur la maltraitance morale parce que là
ça va relever plus de la négociation et
de la
de raisonner en fait ou en tout cas de
former les personnes à la manière dont
on s'occupe des animaux à vos actions
ambition se tournent autour de trois
axes le d'assurer la défense et la
protection des animaux qu'est-ce que ça
signifie alors concrètement c'est un
aspect répressif voilà nous on est une
association de terrain on va se rendre
directement sur le terrain pour se
courir les animaux qui sont maltraités
qui sont battus qui sont en train de
mourir sans soin etc c'est le cœur on va
dire de notre mission c'est l'essentiel
de nos activités c'est vraiment le
terrain et travailler en collaboration
avec les forces de l'ordre pour retirer
en fait les animaux maltraités c'est
voilà le coeur aussi finalement de vos
actions c'est de de travailler avec les
forces de l'ordre pour pouvoir sauver
justement ces animaux maltraités
exactement il faut savoir que les
associations ne sont pas assez remontées
donc on ne peut pas nous association
aller chez les gens comme ça et retirer
des animaux sans accord judiciaire donc
on est toujours obligé d'intervenir avec
les forces de l'ordre pour faire des
constatations pour qu'on ait une
autorisation de saisie et aussi parce
que derrière systématiquement il y a des
dépôts de plainte et des poursuites
devant les tribunaux le deuxième axe
c'est la sensibilisation de l'opinion
publique et des quelles actions
mettez-vous en place justement pour
sensibiliser les citoyens la
maltraitance animale alors on a pris le
parti nous de mettre en image nos
sauvetages donc sur nos réseaux sociaux
sur notre site internet etc on raconte
en fait en images les histoires des
animaux qu'on a ce couru sans sans mise
en scène en fait c'est très cru quoi
c'est très brut enfin il y a pas
vraiment de montage et ça permet de
mettre en lumière la réalité en fait de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en France et
ça permet énormément de sensibiliser les
gens parce qu'on a beaucoup de personnes
qui qui ne se doutent pas de la manière
dont se déroule une intervention et de
la manière dont peuvent être traités les
animaux ce sont parfois des mêmes des
images dures un des images choc dont on
peut être confronté finalement en
regardant vos vidéos malgré tout ce sont
des images choc mais ce sont également
et surtout la réalité c'est exactement
ça on a beaucoup réfléchi à savoir s'il
fallait ou pas
traverser la réalité pour la rendre un
peu plus supportable aux yeux des gens
et on a décidé que non que voilà la
jamais été elle est comme ça et que si
les gens ne se rendent pas compte de ce
qui se passe on aura du mal à faire
évaluer un petit peu les choses derrière
et enfin troisième axe assurer le
respect des lois protégeant les animaux
et l'environnement c'est loin de les
connaît pas toujours et surtout on a
l'impression que la maltraitance animale
par exemple n'est pas souvent puni c'est
ce qu'on a dit il y a un instant est-ce
que votre objectif c'est aussi de vous
adresser aux élus de la République pour
faire évoluer ses lois c'est tout à fait
notre objectif
faut savoir que dans notre équipe on
était beaucoup à travailler pour
d'autres structures nationales on avait
déjà des relations avec les ministères
la dégel etc et là l'objectif est très
clairement de permettre l'évolution des
lois en passant du du bas du terrain en
fait de la réalité de terrain jusqu'au
sommet de l'État pour qu'en fait le bas
soit entendu et pris en compte et qu'on
puisse comme ça amener des propositions
ou en tout cas des éléments qui
permettront de faire évoluer les textes
protection de protection des animaux
mais sur votre site internet également à
vous vous partagez les les comment dire
les les sauvetages que que vous réalisez
avec des fois des photos vous donnez
également des nouvelles un des animaux
donc vous ne partagez pas seulement les
images dures mais aussi les belles
images de des sauvetages des animaux
quand ils ont réussi à évoluer quand ils
ont réussi à se reconstruire finalement
ça aussi c'est une partie de votre
travail de de montrer que oui un animal
a été brisé mais qu'on peut toujours le
sauver tout à fait on a beaucoup de bah
alors déjà il faut savoir que les
animaux qu'on retire notre principal
mission notre principal le notre souhait
le plus cher c'est de les replacer dans
des belles familles derrière l'idée
c'est qu'il soit heureux ces animaux là
on les retire pas puis après on les
laisse pas moisir tout seul dans leur
coin et effectivement c'est important de
montrer que on a des animaux qui peuvent
avoir vécu des pires atrocités qui vont
se révéler de parfaits chiens de famille
alors bien sûr parfois ça peut laisser
des traces d'être asphyziques on a des
animaux qui sont bah qui sont bas à
l'Afrique qui sont pas forcément
esthétiquement acceptable aux yeux des
gens mais et ça peut laisser des traces
psychologiques aussi mais avec de
l'amour de la patience on arrive à tout
aujourd'hui on n'a pas un seul animal
qu'on considère comme définitivement
perdu on va dire donc on arrive toujours
à les réhabiliter et surtout c'est les
animaux qui se réhabilitent même avec
une capacité de résilience qui est
incroyable qui arrive à nouveau à faire
confiance alors que bah voilà
malheureusement parfois ils ont vraiment
vécu des horreurs quoi alors qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire justement quand on est
témoin de de maltraitance animale et ce
qu'on doit vous contacter directement
est-ce qu'on doit contacter les forces
de l'ordre qui vous contactent après
comment ça se passe finalement alors ça
dépend du cas si c'est une situation
avec une urgence vitale par exemple
quelqu'un qui est en train de massacrer
son chien là c'est il faut faire le 17
parce que voilà la police la gendarmerie
ce sont les personnes les plus déjà
c'est de leur ressort et en plus ce sont
les personnes les plus à même à être sur
place le plus vite possible nous on sera
pas forcément sur place à la minute donc
première réflexe on fait le 17 deuxième
réflexe on nous appelle comme ça nous on
peut se mettre en rapport avec la police
pour éventuellement leur expliquer la
marche à suivre pour récupérer l'animal
derrière etc si on n'est pas dans une
situation d'urgence vitale mais dans une
maltraitance plutôt passive
il faut faire un signalement directement
bah en ligne sur notre site avec
l'adresse tous les éléments qui les
personnes ont à leur possession pour
qu'on a une ou vérifier les conditions
de vie de l'animal et si le faux qu'on
fasse intervenir la police derrière et
une fois l'animal récupéré qu'est-ce qui
se passe pour une fois l'animal récupéré
il va se retrouver soit le place en
famille d'accueil s'il est très abîmé
malheureusement ça arrive soit en place
en pension on va il va voir un
vétérinaire on va évoluer un petit peu
évaluer un petit peu son comportement et
ensuite l'idée c'est qu'on puisse le
replacer directement soit dans des
familles soit via des refuges
partenaires avec qui on travaille pour
que l'animal puisse avoir une vie de
famille épanouie on a vu un sur votre
sur votre site internet début mars par
exemple vous aviez sauvé ficelle une
border collie certains médias ont relayé
l'information elle a été victime de
maltraitance on a eu aussi deux chiens
souffrant de malnutrition extrême et un
chien enfermé dans 80 CM2 ces chiens là
ces animaux qui sont victimes justement
de de maltraitance animale ils sont
brisés ils ont un caractère malgré tout
comment est-ce que vous faites pour
justement leur redonner confiance en
l'humain alors il faut savoir que un
animal qui a été qui a vécu des horreurs
va immédiatement s'attacher et faire
confiance à la première personne qui va
être gentille avec lui voilà c'est
horrible mais c'est aussi leur force et
en fait de cette confiance là on peut on
peut permettre à l'animal d'évoluer et
de passer à autre chose donc ça peut
prendre du temps ça passe aussi beaucoup
par la confiance et la nourriture parce
que ça c'est le meilleur le chemin de
lait du coeur prend souvent celui de
l'estomac et voilà après les chiens
surtout les chats un petit peu moins
mais les chiens sont surtout à des
animaux très résilients qui arrivent
très vite à passer à autre chose donc
voilà tout est une question de temps de
patience et d'amour c'est toujours bon
de le rappeler mais les animaux ne sont
ni déjoués ni des passe-temps et la
maltraitance animale et animale pardon
il puni par la loi alors avant d'adopter
un animal de compagnie vaut mieux
réfléchir à deux fois merci beaucoup
Anne-Claire chevancy d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur
votre sur votre site action protection
animale.com ou sur votre Instagram
Facebook et YouTube action protection
animale et pour revoir ou réécouter
cette émission rendez-vous sur notre
site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]